your Innovation Lab max HVF just
announced a new company and a product
today called asymmetric ax and a sim
which is the the plugin that allows it
to be possible when I saw this I was
like this is exactly what I need but it
basically makes it easier to read yeah
it improves your comprehension through
what's called micro typography it
instantly and very nice English really
almost introduces special spacing
between words and letters on any webpage
creates these word bundles we actually
have the way it looks on here the
original and and what it looks like with
a sim so explain to me what's going on
so they're about 40 years of academic
research this shows that humans
comprehend text when clauses are
separated slightly better visually than
when they're just typeset kind of a
standard way and the comprehension can
grow up up to 40 percent so you could be
a 40% better reader which I certainly
could use so and it works with any link
that you click on exactly so it's a
browser plugin created by two guys that
started the company in hvf as I was
getting busier video with a firm I
didn't forget about trying crazy
projects then this is one of these
things one of these guys ken brownfield
worked with me on almost every project
I've ever started so I'm super excited
to see him actually build a company
inside the lab but the product is
amazing it's something that you add to
your browser works with every major
browser it's a plugin and it
automatically completely transparently
changes the layout of every text page
that you encounter on the web and makes
it ever so slightly more readable very
cool you also have some news out of a
firm today you're getting into student
loans specifically loans for people who
want to go to like coding or design
movers yeah why student loans and why
take on this big issue of student debt
so it's actually super super
straightforward so we built this company
are building this company on this
premise that the world needs honest
financing financial products financial
services banks have lost their
credibility with the new generation the
Millennials do not trust enough like big
banks and they are looking for something
better the number one to me best use of
credits for a person is to borrow money
to invest in themselves make themselves
a more employable more hireable
higher earning able person and so it
just seemed inappropriate for us not to
be lending to students now the best for
my money or at least in my opinion kind
of education today is if you can go and
get yourself a 10-week program that
takes you from a geography major who is
probably not very hireable in today's
economy to a JavaScript developer or a
product manager or a graphic designer
which typically quadruples your earning
capacity that is a great way to
participate in the economy and the one
thing I've stopping more people from
taking these classes is lack of
financial aid and that's where we come
in and quickly how do you assess the
risk that a firm is taking on here as
because as we know student debt is a
problem defaults are a problem it
certainly is that is our specialty we
are a bunch of young and old and that
includes a bunch of ex PayPal people
that have really cutter teeth on
assessing risk we look at all the data
that we use for our point-of-sale
product at the merchant checkouts and
some other kinds of data we're still
testing lots of new models including
potentially looking people's code
quality to see how well it correlates to
repayment but we're confident we can
take on the risk